hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning
spoilers ahead today i'm gonna explain
an american suspenseful survival movie
called detour
the film begins by showing a man who
wakes up from his unconsciousness named
jackson looks like he just had an
accident he immediately looks around but
there is no sunlight at all
in other words his car was already
buried in the ground
he tries to open his car door but his
efforts are in vain because the door is
blocked
frantically he tries to call 911 but
unfortunately his cell phone signal is
not connecting at all
he then tries to find a radio frequency
but it is also not detected he also
tries to start the car's engine but the
car has already broken down
not long after there is a shock that
causes the car to move deeper he thinks
if there is a shock like this then he is
sure that he wasn't buried in the flat
ground
he also records himself using his cell
phone as a form of information in case
he cannot be saved later
feeling pessimistic about the situation
he doesn't know what to do
he also hopes that the rescue team will
soon find out about this incident
currently the clock is showing 1pm
indicating that there is still a chance
he will be saved he then tries to
remember what happened as he is drawing
his journey on the notebook
at first everything was fine on the trip
but there was an incident that suddenly
happened to him causing his car to get
buried underground
then he realizes the sunroof has started
to crack due to the enormous pressure of
the ground
obviously that is not a good thing
especially since he can only stay in his
car and cannot do anything
the air conditioner can only emit dust
making red ants enter the car through
the hole
he immediately covers the hole with
masking tape
he panics even more because until now
there is no sign that he will be saved
feeling depressed he decides to watch
the video on his cell phone his fiancee
laurie is seen in the video
after that he plans to sleep while
conserving his cell phone battery
long story short he wakes up from his
sleep and he realizes that it is already
9 pm he has been waiting underground for
about 8 hours but there is still no sign
of help coming for him
jack who is starting to get short of
breath tries to find an opening so he
can breathe freely when he opens his car
window the dirt spills out and gets
inside the soil texture is also still
wet and soft indicating a mudslide
meanwhile the cracks in his sunroof are
getting worse he immediately patches the
glass with the masking tape he also uses
a steering wheel lock to hold the mass
off the ground
fortunately the way he does it is quite
effective
he then unconsciously drinks the water
until it runs out he just realizes that
it is the only water he currently has
he starts to pray at that time
when he finishes he realizes that
praying alone is not enough but he has
to do his best to get out of there
suddenly he gets an idea to check his
luggage and find some useful things he
initially drinks the water dripping from
the ground
back then he doesn't care whether the
water is safe to drink or not he then
makes a small hole in the sunroof to
hold the water in his empty bottle
it feels very bad as jack has to pee in
his own car
soon he takes some parts from his car
seat to make some iron pipes he then
makes another hole in the sunroof to
allow the pipes to penetrate upwards
jack takes the bottle cap to make a hole
in it and ties it with rope to keep the
pipe straight up before continuing with
his work he eats the only biscuit to
stifle his hunger he also drinks the
contaminated water that has been
accommodated earlier after eating he
continues to push the pipe up the
depletion of oxygen forces him to make a
hole for breathing
after seeing the light outside he
immediately checks the depth of the
ground with the rope he made before
apparently the ground above is
approximately three meters deep
he shouts as loudly as he can with hope
that someone will hear him as he
breathes through the hole
then he has another idea by making smoke
through the pipe so the smoke can be
seen by the others but then the fire
gets bigger and out of control
fortunately he still can extinguish the
fire
when he wants to check the hole there is
another shock that makes his head hit
the iron pipe making him unconscious for
a while
shortly after he wakes up with a sore
head he immediately removes his shirt
and belt as a bandage to stop the
bleeding as the result he can only sit
limpy thinking of ways to survive
a few hours later jack's head wound is
seen oozing pus indicating that the
wound is infected
suddenly there is another shock that
makes the back of his car begin to
collapse
inevitably he has to hold up the back of
his car with the rest of the iron pipes
jack who feels very thirsty has to drink
his own urine he then takes the car
tires and plugs it into the pump hose to
keep him breathing from the air inside
the tire
in desperation he decides to dig the
ground above him to get out of the place
he also applies oil all over his body to
keep it slippery when it penetrates the
hard ground
this decision is made purposely by him
to survive even though he is not sure
either
furthermore he immediately destroys the
sunroof so the ground above it can
descend into his car
while carrying the car tires to breathe
jack slowly tries to dig up the ground
at some point he is finally able to
stand on top of his car
on the other hand the air in the car
tires is getting thinner but suddenly
for the umpteenth time there is another
shock that makes his whole body covered
with dirt amazingly there is little
movement that indicates jack is still
alive
after a long time he manages to reach
the ground and he also can see the
sunlight again
in the end he manages to survive the
mudslide he has just experienced
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching